so let's do some positional training
so these are positional problems from
ogre's book excelling at positional
chest jacob boggart is of course
a very famous chess author and he
produces very good material
this is from excelling at positional
chest let us begin
with the first problem it is white to
play
[Music]
so whichever side we are facing it is
that side uh to move
and uh in this first problem it is white
to play let me just check that that is
indeed the position yes it is
white to move okay so
i guess uh let's begin by figuring out
what's going on let's count the material
so currently
it's an end game clearly um queens are
off the board
queens are off the board we have two
three four five six seven against six so
white is down upon
and white has the possibility of playing
bishop takes d6
um so the the obvious move is to just
recapture the pawn on d6 i will move the
pieces just for the sake of the
audience now for the sake of you guys
normally if i'd solve these i wouldn't
move the pieces
but uh it doesn't it's not essential in
positional exercises because we're not
really training our calculation
you had a game against nakamura this
time oh that's pretty cool i think this
is is this like a slav
line marshall so um we can do this we
can reclaim the pawn now the issue with
that the ish
is that i really like the bishop uh
clearly as we'll discuss in just a
second this bishop
is is incredibly strong and i think it
could be used in a much better way than
than given up for
for the sake of a pawn for the sake of
restoring material equality
now what exactly is black going to do i
feel like here
white is probably slightly better
but um i'm not exactly sure
let's say king e7 right this attacks the
rook now let's say
if mike moves the rook then black can
just simply get his bishop out to d7 i
really don't buy that white is
is any better at all really so
i really don't buy the white is any
better at all if white goes c5 here to
try to cement the rook
bishop d7 even here is final rook d8
forces the rook trade so to me
uh i wouldn't say it's like a draw per
se but it looks like an equal end game
and i feel like white is shooting for an
advantage now let's take a look at the
other
possibilities we can consciously refuse
to take the pawn we can move the bishop
somewhere the question is where do we
want to move the bishop
let's try to evaluate the candidates i
see two
off the top of my head two candidate
moves for the bishop one as you guys are
pointing out is bishop b6
and this is kind of this looks cool
because it clamps down on
on the entire queen side and the bishop
seems pretty unassailable here
the other one seems bishop seems to be
bishop a3
so let's try to evaluate the pros and
cons
of these two moves and make a decision i
feel like it's going to be one of these
two
both of these to be honest seem better
to me than bishop takes these i feel
like white's contending for an advantage
uh in in both of these cases now my
intuition is telling me bishop a3 but
i will give a fair trial to bishop b6 so
what exactly is white's next move going
to be here because eventually we do want
to get to this point i don't want to
just play down upon
but we have a lot of possibilities we
can play bishop d3 we can play knight e4
i feel like bishop a3 is better from the
perspective of winning the spawn because
now knight e4
is a pretty serious threat even g4
should be considerable but
that's a pretty weakening move um so
let's say bishop b6
and the the the uh advantage of bishop
b6 is that this bishop is just
ensconced on that square it's very uh
very advanced and it's on an outpost
here's the one thing that worries me the
one thing that worries me about
bishop b6 is let's say black plays it's
simple bishop d7
and um let's say that we go 94 to try to
you know as we discuss to try to take
this pawn with the knight and blacco's
king e7
now it seems to me that black is sort of
getting out
and maybe you can play g4 here honestly
this does look pretty good for one and
then you take on d6 this does look
very very good for what i agree um
but i have a sense that black can
somehow
consolidate here black could also
potentially castle although that doesn't
solve the problem with the pawn
but yeah g4 chases the knight away then
we take the pawn the great thing about
putting the bishop on b6 is that it
covers the d8 square
it makes it impossible for black to
ultimately put his rook on d8
so um with bishop a3 black also has
control of the d4 square so let's take a
look at bishop a3 bishop a3
i mean i don't really envision black
playing anything other than
then let's say bishop bishop d7 and
um you know here we can play perhaps
knight e4 as well and um
you know this also seems good i mean i
feel like these moves are pretty similar
in value but i really i do i am starting
to like the mood bishop b6 because here
yeah but rook d8 once again black and
played g4 but maybe black can play h5
here
in order to prevent g4 and if you play
knight takes d6
takes takes this is you know this is
playable for black i feel like this is
play but i would love
for the bishop to be on b6 now to
control that square so let's go with
bishop b6
i think bishop b6 is the better
long-term decision
although something actually tells me
that maybe knight e5 is a good defensive
resource for like but even here like
9497 bishop c7
and black is just so cramped here so i
like the move bishop b6
let's check out the solution
um and let's read agard's explanation
shall we
okay so let's go this is exercise five
it's gonna be important for me not to
like
see the solutions to the subsequent
problems because we're gonna do a couple
uh exercise one oh that he puts them on
separate pages exercise five ways to
move
this is a really dif okay i'm reading
this is a really difficult exercise
there is no clear-cut way of deciding
between the various possibilities
white should consider whether the two
bishops are enough for the pawn deficit
and this appears to be the case
if we compare pieces and squares the d6
pawn is soft and will most likely fall
um anyway 94 is a possibility the choice
is now how white should choose to
maintain the bishops exactly as we had
discussed
this was porch noy against timon cortney
took on d6
uh and he gives it a question mark this
affords black easy development and
restores his control over the white
squares indeed white should be careful
now
alternatives bishop a3x glam seems best
black is weak on a number of dark
squares but it is only d6 e7 and d4 he
is trying to control
now e5 is practically forced
e5 he says that's not an easy move to
see as it is hard to see any other moves
okay so e5 bishop v6 is an interesting
move which with some justification
the key idea is to prevent black from
playing rook t8 to protect the d6 spawn
later white will
attack it with bishop c7 and 94. my main
objection to this move is that the
knight in many lines after bishop a3
comes to b6 and dominates completely so
what he basically is saying
is that we should leave this square for
the bishop but he does say that this is
interesting so
we essentially made the right uh
decision not to take on d6
uh let's check the engine let's check
the current stockfish 12 to see which
move is better
and uh let's see which move stockfish
prefers here
and then we'll go on to the next problem
this is called excelling at positional
chess okay
so
this is a bit of an old book so maybe
stockfish will just like refute all
these lines
yeah so here's the funny thing
so bishop b6 it's saying
it's saying h5 is the only equalizing
move
and now it's saying the position is
equal here's the hilarious thing okay
bishop a3 is
a little bit better but but it's saying
that after every move it's equal like
bishop takes d6 bishop a3
and bishop b6 are equivalent okay now
it's saying bishop a3 is slightly better
yeah bishop a3
is definitely the best practical choice
i would say bishop b6 is not bad
uh but the real lesson to learn here is
that you don't want to grab pawns just
for the sake of grabbing them
sometimes the positional advantages are
well h5 stops g4 i
i mentioned this move this this move
stops g4 um
but yeah this is a gm level puzzle but
what this teaches is that in some
positions
uh it is worth keeping certain
positional advantages
over grabbing a pawn i think that's the
basic lesson of this problem
okay uh but that was a difficult one
that was definitely
definitely not a clear-cut puzzle but
nonetheless that's that's a good lesson
to learn let's move on to
to the next one um okay so let me go
into the oh there we go okay
so here's the new position uh white to
play
and uh let's delve delve into it let's
delve into it so
material is equal it's a six on six
situation if we count the pawns
um now clearly white is better i mean
there's no doubt in my mind the first
thing i notice is that white is better
positionally and the reason why it is
better
is because well there's a couple things
right first of all this knight is
beautiful look at this knight on that
outpost
black is super cramped and black is a
bunch of these weaknesses you know like
one thing that comes to mind immediately
is the b6 bond is very weak
and the reason it's weak is because it's
not defended by any other pawns black
seems to be tied down to it
so an immediate item on a on my wish
list
would be if we could remove this knight
from d7 then we would basically crash
through
via via b6 now
it would be very nice if we could play
if we could play bishop g4 in this
position that would be amazing
uh unfortunately we can't so you know
one thing that that could be considered
here is the move g4
uh but but but but wait there's a
problem with this move the problem with
this move he's not going to cooperate
by allowing us to take black is going to
play the move h4 most
certainly and uh the question is have we
achieved anything as a result
of these two moves and let's think about
that first thing let me think about that
i mean we could try g5 yeah yeah we
could try g5 but the problem guys is
that we sacrifice a pawn
and we weaken our king and if bishop g4
he's going to shut that operation down
by playing f5
this is a very typical mistake you've
got to be very careful about checking
your opponent's resources it's not only
about
what you want to do it's also about
whether you give your opponent a little
bit too much so
it i mean in general i think it's a good
idea
to provoke but here's try this on for
side i have an idea
what if we start with the move h4
in order to freeze black spawn and then
we go g4
and the idea is twofold first of all
we're also kind of a
website we're also kind of attacking
black's king and if we open all of these
files we're going to be attacking
black's king
so we might go h4 here freeze the pawn
and then on the next move
we might want to go g4 potentially and
maybe even we go king h3 first
to protect the spawn the thing to
remember is that if we go g4
and black takes on h4 then we simply go
gh and our queen also attacks the bishop
there's one other idea and always in
these puzzles you want to
consider other ideas as well you want to
force yourself to consider these other
ideas
and another idea is to make the move
bishop e2 i think this is
this is the like obvious move because
you're just aiming at the a6 bond i mean
that seems very reasonable doesn't it
and uh if black plays a5 here the
question is have
has white really gained anything well
white's game to be five square that's
for certain white could even stick the
queen there
and what appeals to me about this option
is that it really
clamps down on black's position even
further so forcing a5 may be
a much simpler approach than going h4
but h4 is very fancy and it's more
ambitious and i really like it
um the other thing that black may have
in response to bishop a2
is um let's see yeah black has a very
hard time actually defending the spawn i
mean if we can force rook a8
then that's definitely a win for white
hmm
so bishop a2 this seems almost forced to
me and now we can even move the queen
to f4 we can even move the queen to f4
and reserve the b5 square for white's
bishop
and then at our leisure we could try to
target the knight that way
rocaine is not a win for white okay oh a
win in terms of
well because now look at this rook what
is this rook doing it's like
literally staring at the spawn now we
could play h4 and just this idea would
be much stronger
so the move rook c1 i don't like because
black has the c5 square for his knight
remember once we go roxy one we've taken
our eyes off of the b6 spawn so the
knight can now move
um i am going to go ladies and gentlemen
with bishop e2 i think it's worth
inducing a5 and i don't see why the why
we are in a hurry
to play a move like h4 on the other hand
it
is i will acknowledge very very tempting
to go h4 followed by g4 but i feel like
this is a little bit too
flimsy i feel like this is just a tad
too flimsy
although i think both ideas are probably
quite decent but let's go with bishop e2
with the potential idea of going h4
hopefully one of these two is correct
and it's okay when you're solving these
problems it's not necessarily about
exactly getting everything right
you want to basically get the general
gist of it right and
my guess is that both moves are probably
okay let's read the solution drum roll
please
drum roll please okay karpov
against portish tilburg 1988 white
clearly has a space advantage and
prospect of an attack against the enemy
pawns
his best b stands on c6 which can be
neutralized by black's knight
but just not right now bishop e2 is a
fine move
but black would never play a5 i don't
know why he's jumping to that conclusion
losing what is left
of his plan so rook a8 is actually the
only move that's what he says
now oh this position haven't already
been on the board in fact now jeff after
g4 why did
white appears to have achieved um a
favorable version of the game which also
gave him an advantage however concrete
calculation
reveals that the black rook is better
placed on a8 than on
e8 if the world collapses apparently ah
apparently after hg bishop takes g4
black has the move knight c5
and after queen takes b6 queen takes b6
rook takes b6 if the rook was on e8 here
this pawn on a6 would be undefended but
my point to you guys is that we don't
have to rush with the move g4 i like h4
in this position so
we're going to check this with an engine
augard's move
his stated solution is g4 exclamation
mark he does give
g4 as the solution h4 he says is dubious
merely creates a weakness on the dark
squares
a possible variation is king g7 x
preparing for g3 g4 and he gives g4 a
question mark
takes takes and now he says rookie shade
gives black cow to play which does make
some sense
um okay so after h4
he says that queen f ah this is a key
move queen f4
is a very strong move what does queen f4
prepare
what does queen f4 prepare so we we
we got parts of it right but he does
claim that the media g4
is best oh it prepares g5 it prepares g5
and now the spot on h4 is weak so
we had to look at this position a little
bit deeper and one of the mistakes that
i made here
here's one of the mistakes that i made i
got
fixated on this pawn i assume that the
queen has to remain on before
to tie down the knight but you have to
be very flexible a piece could be doing
one job in one position
and it might need to do another job in
another position and
this idea of very of being very fluid in
response to where your pieces belong is
very important
uh and here as long as you realize that
the queen doesn't have to remain on p4
it's
it's easier to find this idea but
nonetheless he does say bishop e2
is a decent move he doesn't however like
h4 let's
confirm this with stockfish and let's
see how the engine chooses to play this
position you guys can see how i'm using
the engine i'm not
anti-engine i do you know
appreciate what the engine says because
ultimately it's important
okay engine says bishop e2 best move
yeah bishop e2 best move
and um after rook a
but yeah g4 here g4 and if h4 then queen
f4 is just winning
you cannot stop the move g5 because if
black plays g5 himself then white has
queen f5
and after bishop d3 this battery is
going to be horrible so bishop b2 is is
good
tying down the uh a6 pawn but here h4
is inaccurate indeed because of king g7
and the the medicine here is worse than
the
actually no it does like h4 so we
let's let's count this as a win although
uh it is very instructive
that we shouldn't get fixated on the way
that a particular piece is placed
all right does that make sense let's do
one more and let's go back to the
problems and set it up
crumbly cheesecake thank you for the
tier one let's do exercise number
seven uh let's do number
number eight now that seems a little bit
juicier
and this one's gonna be black to move so
just for some variety
um it's so material one two three four
five six seven eight so all eight pawns
for both sides on the board it's a very
close position
and in a cl closed positions are are
what i think a lot of people thank you
guys this is very sweet
close positions i think are what a lot
of people need to work on because
a lot of people hate close positions
they can be very hard to deconstruct
and i would really encourage you to pay
attention to two main things
in closed positions the first
is squares squares are incredibly
important because the way that you
infiltrate in a closed position is
through weak squares
you can't infiltrate through the center
so you kind of have to use weak squares
you're kind of climbing a wall
you know grabbing onto the rocks if that
makes sense or you're grabbing onto
debris
um and if we look at the weak squares in
in black's position
it's quite concerning thank you pistol
cat gifting to psych sock
because you can see that these two
squares you know white can go bishop g4
and if he ever manages to stick a knight
on f5
that just doesn't seem particularly
um appealing the other thing that you
need to pay attention to in my opinion
is ways that we can open up the position
you need to be aware
of the various pawn breakthroughs that
at some point
can open up the position and you need to
be more prepared than your opponent
when that moment comes to push the pawn
thank you uh yumi
simile for the prime you've got eye
train rolling appreciate it guys
so uh the movie h5 does make sense from
the perspective of stopping
the trade of light squared bishops but
uh i think just bishop takes h5 i don't
see what you get in return for the pawn
you do open up the h file but i just
don't think it's worth it
so h5 does blend to the pawn
what else so what are the pawn
breakthroughs well for whites
f4 seems to be the potential pawn
breakthrough but that's never really
happening right because look at how many
sorry let me remove some of these arrows
look at how many defenders
black has on the force where black has
three pieces on that scratch just don't
see it happening anytime soon thank you
the recluse
for the prime so it appears to be the
kind of situation where
black on the other hand does have the
capacity to prepare f5 and he can
prepare it by dropping the queen back
this does prepare the move at five the
issue here is that white will play
bishop g4 i think
white is going to play bishop g4 and
prevent black from playing f5 i think
so i'm not sure i like queen g7 and as i
explained guys h5
i think just blunders the funnel though
i don't really uh
and i don't really see what black gets
in in return
so this tells me that maybe there is
some some hidden way to improve
our position in a sort of specific way i
mean we can play bishop d7 but
i feel like there's something that is a
little bit more meaty
if that makes sense a little bit more
meat to the move
let me think i'm actually gonna pause
for a second guys and think
okay so we can go there and sacrifice i
do want to stop
bishop g4 can we find some
sort of prophylaxis against bishop
g4 we got a raiden coming it appears
well
well we can castle but i'm not sure what
that gives you right i'm not sure what
castling really gives
uh but here's another idea oh andrew
tang is that's fantastic
yeah so this is a very
very tricky one guys well we
first of all we cannot whoa holy smokes
bishop a6 blunders the bishop guys
always check for tactics because of the
spark ladies and gentlemen thank you
andrew
for the raid guys you come at a good
time we are doing actually some training
i am solving some positional exercises
very difficult
grand master level positional exercises
from
uh the book excelling at positional
chess by jacob auger that's something
relatively new
i've never done this before and we are
really suffering through
some tough positional exercises but i
think we're all learning along the way
including me
um and we are currently on this problem
it is black to play
and we're definitely struggling well
guys so queen g7
white will play bishop g4 i think this
is andrew's kind of position i think he
can definitely
help us out here the problem is i think
white has this positional threat of
bishop g4
so here's another thought
here's another thought this is easy says
brandon
i thought you were a champion so let me
think here
oh h5 is also something that was
suggested but i just don't think
you know we can allow bishop takes h5
i'm just not seeing it there
yeah so knight f8 is a very interesting
idea i was
thinking about that one as well knight
f8 is very interesting from the
perspective of preparing f5 chess kid
111 i really like that proposal
yes i think this is a very nice idea
actually because here's the thing
not only does this prepare five and we
got i got a very sweet message just want
to read out
f5 er one thanks for these streams they
have a lot
they have meant a lot to me over the
past couple years and helped me with my
depression but my mom passed away a
couple days ago
um whoa
um
first of all i'm sorry to hear that but
i got a lot more chess to teach so
you know at least
at least you can get to 2000.
at least help me with some positional
exercises
this community is always going to be
here for you i'm i feel
i truly do feel your pain um
as i suffered a similar loss in the past
year and
um you know please do stick around we
would appreciate it
this community is always going to be
here for you
yeah that is i'm truly truly sorry to
hear that but
um
there are plenty of people in this
community who will
hold you up and i got a lot more to
teach so
there's a lot more speed runs to come at
the very least
you can't miss you can't miss the rapid
speed run
so absolutely thanks guys
so i i wish you the very best you know
stay strong
and uh there's there's nothing i could
say to
ease the pain but uh
chess i think can offer the best kind of
escape as it has
for me for for many many years
okay um
absolutely yeah thank you guys uh really
appreciate the love and
once again i'm sorry to hear that
but uh just like chess positions can be
lost
and you can swindle them you can
absolutely get out of i believe
many many tough situations so
that's what i'll say for now i'll let
you i'll let you have your peace
but thank you grant owen ah coach grant
for five five gifted
i appreciated coach coach grant yeah
this is an awesome community truly and
uh
you can see how much love is is being
sent so let's let's work on this puzzle
and if you have any thoughts on this
puzzle i need i need i need some help so
okay so
i i do like the idea of going that f8
and queen g6 here
uh and and the bottom line here is we
want to prepare a five
now if um if you play
queen g7 the the problem here is that it
is it is much
more difficult to get f5 in
is much more difficult to get a 5n than
it is
in this situation because the queen is
actually contributing
to the support of f5 and actually f5 is
now
a a threat f5 is actually a threat and
so for example if if white takes on c8
then after rook takes c8
we are attacking e4 and we are preparing
f5 so
credit here to to mr chess kid i wonder
who who your coach is uh clearly
finding pretty good positional ideas so
we like that f8 and potentially this
night
if you think about where this knight
could go it could later swing around to
f6
it could later swing around to f6 and
it could apply pressure on the e4 phone
so i'm going to go with that f8 guys
that's a nice idea yeah i know it's
some some just some total
airhead basically okay
let's see let's
see exercise eight you suppose against
lutz wow okay wait this is oh no no that
was the wrong exercise
no it is king d a king c7 so closed
positions are often the most difficult
to play and unfortunately you cannot
always avoid them
here black needs to organize his forces
in the best possible way
the primary concern for black in this
position is to find a safe
heaven for his king this is not so easy
players with prior knowledge of this
type of position can probably find some
of the ideas
but the initial concept is very
difficult to find first castling king's
side seems very dangerous
white will not find it too difficult to
attack the h6 g5 pawn duo
in view in view of the missing dark
squared bishop
and black has little chance of creating
active counter play on the queen side in
time
secondly castling long would send the
king the right way but at the same time
leave the defending pieces on the king
side so the right move according to him
is king d8
bishop g4 king c7 so i guess it was a
question of priorities to me
the priority was not king safety i
didn't really see how white could
generate an attack but um i suppose
the point here is that the king is the
top priority
the king c7 um bishop g4 king c7 rook b1
rook b8 and the game sort of ends in a
drop
so let's actually check uh no let's
check the engine i mean but this is a
pretty old book so
that doesn't necessarily mean we are
wrong that doesn't necessarily mean we
are wrong
and uh i have some good news for you
so knight of fate is
not bad yeah no it does like 88 though i
mean white is better here
white is actually better but yeah this
is the best idea and knight f8
um i guess we were basically going for
an advantage the problem with knight f8
is
that white will go a4 and um
well okay black goes a5 and y can go h4
so i suppose the
the point is uh black just doesn't have
time to prepare
uh queen g6 followed by a five and the
reason is
uh white is just going to tear him apart
here before black gets a chance to play
f5
so the question here is is one of
priorities
well the reason king safety is the
priority is because
white has all of these threats on both
sides of the board so you need to find
that
relative safety for the king and at the
same time you also need to link up the
rooks
so well if white plays knight g4 then
black plays queen g7 thank you puke
monkey for the prime
i suppose this makes this makes sense
this does make sense
so the king gets out of the way of the
rooks the king gets to a spot where it's
at least protected by this uh
by this pawn chain that's a very very
difficult exercise and i myself am not a
specialist in these types of positions
so
i i suppose in certain situations you
have to come to terms with the fact that
you're not going to have too much active
play
and then you have to find the best way
to make the most
out of you know a tough situation and so
here
you have to get the king to safety
um would magnus find king d i mean
probably
it's not the only move i mean the the
differences here aren't very big
it's like plus equals after king d8 and
knight f8 it's like plus point eight
so you know
yeah we all are principia but
you know
yeah so the f5 idea does take a while
yeah definitely
definitely and that's that's the bottom
line issue the problem is once you move
the knight to f8
white white is going to go h4 and
white's going to tear apart that h fun
so that's a very interesting puzzle very
instructive closed positions
are among the hardest to play that i
agree with let's do one last one let's
do one final problem
and then we might wrap up with some more
bullets
exercise nine it's going to be white to
move in
the following end game
okay
and excuse me i want to make it clear
that these exercises
it's more really about learning concepts
than it is about
getting questions right as you can see
you know some of these questions
are kind of open-ended the difference
between like the best move and the
second best move is not terribly best
uh so it's more about you know filing
into your brain
the logic that constitutes the best move
that's what
that's what you ultimately retain not
necessarily like an individual variation
that's just my opinion not trying to
like justify it but
that's what you're really trying to do
here okay
um
this is actually no i mean this is like
i am gm level problem so it's certainly
very instructor for me
uh this is definitely very instructive
for me and uh
i i do this on my own okay
so white has the so it's an end game
equal pawns
why does the two bishops but what occurs
to me is two things
first of all this is a pass spawn so
that needs to be you need to watch out
about that pawn
second of all this bishop is kind of
faster so it would be great
if we could play something like c4 the
problem is well c4 gives up upon and i'm
not sure that white gets anything in
return for the other thing to notice is
if we play b5 could somebody explain to
me
and b5 is almost definitely not the
solution although
you know you never know these problems
and there is a case to be made for b5
but why don't i like this move
intuitively
why don't i like this move it yeah i
mean knight c5
there's just no need to give this knight
such a juicy outpost
okay so there have been a couple of
moves suggested in the chat
um one of them is to centralize the
knight with knight t4 and that's
definitely an interesting idea i think
it's interesting to try to get the
knight over to d6
certainly something to to consider
that's one candidate
another candidate move is to go bishop
b5 uh just
you know run the bishop here to b5
attack the knight the problem is that i
think black is bishop c6
and i'm not particularly impressed with
the trade of
bishops on c6 i don't see what white
really gains from that
so that's that's not terribly appealing
to me
um let's see what other options are
available to white here let's think for
a second
isn't this a theoretical i mean i
wouldn't know yeah so another move is
rook d6 and this one i really kind of do
like
uh rook b1 is also interesting in c4
yeah for sure
rookie d6 certainly is interesting but
here's the problem with d6 i'm going to
take
and if you say then i'm going to do this
or even rook c2 here looks pretty nasty
but even takes on rook c1 forces the
rook back
and this is just a draw i definitely
feel like white should be
going for an edge here i mean at least
in this one
chess kid who you know hero the last
problem suggests rook b1 but bishop e4
kind of sends the rook to c1 and i don't
know about that
so let me let me think for a second this
is actually again very very challenging
problems as you guys can see
the logic here is difficult the logic
here is definitely very very difficult
um well you could take on a5
and try to isolate that pawn and attack
it i like the also idea of the doubling
the rooks
but somehow it's not that impressive i
mean black can put his knight on d5
we need to find something something just
that carries a little bit of a punch
let's think yeah i thought about knight
d2 knight c4 knight t6 but once you get
the knight to
once you get the knight to c4 i am going
to have the move bishop a6 in order to
pin the knight
and and win the bishop on e2 so that
doesn't seem terribly appealing to me
either
so let's think c sports
yeah this is just um there's there's a
case to be made for
a lot of different positions a lot of
different ideas
[Music]
well i think bishop b5 is interesting
because after bishop c6 here maybe you
can play knight t4
and after takes you can maybe take and
what's the same white may be a tiny bit
better here but really it's nothing take
stakes and like 95
so no i really doubt it's that
i really doubt it's that but maybe
it's just a very minor improving move
um let me think
hmm anonymous gift or gifting f5
er a sub thank you
well root g6 is interesting but i
explained it's it's it's takes
yeah i just agree to a drop okay
i'm going to yeah i like the idea of
going
out going knight too far i think we
should just keep it simple honestly
i i really wonder what it is the problem
here is that black has knight e5
but i suppose here you can go knight b5
and maybe try to get the knight to d6 so
uh this this might be i think it's not
that but i'm actually very curious what
it is so let's check
let's let's go with knight to d4 and
it's going to be one of these moves i'm
just curious what the logic
is i'm really curious what the logic is
um it also might be takes in c4 yeah i
mean it might be c4 but here again
is black really worse here black can go
knight c5 and
you know offer draw basically i really
don't see how white gets an advantage in
this position
um so let's see
let's let's check and then we will we
will pause there exercise
nine this is the game
this is the game you super rosenthal's
white is generally well placed here but
so is black
both sides have completed development
but this is not the middle game
and there's no possibility of attacking
the kings it's probably going to be like
king f1
consequently it is more precise to talk
about the transition from middle game to
endgame
since no immediate action is any good
why should improve something that is the
king king f1
yeah he says knight e4 is interesting
bishop d5
bishop b5 is similar drawback since
there's bishop c6
so yeah he does he does give this line
and says this is not very good he says
knight e4
is interesting with bishop d5 equalizes
and so king f1
you guys definitely propose this move
and it improves the position
and this is kind of a healthy waiting
move let's check
the engine let's see if stockfish
approves of this move
yeah i get just get the king and prove
it and uh you know basically toss the
ball back into black's core
amazing i have some crazy
okay knight d2 actually is a very good
move so knight d2 is indeed
one of the top moves it actually
computer likes b5
the computer actually likes the move b5
wow and the move knight d4
is equal and after king f1 it's also
equal after bishop d5
so b5 now what the hell happens after
knights
ah so i think i understood something
about this
here's the thing the move b
the move b5 may create a weakness on c5
but it also creates a weakness on b6
and white goes knight e5 or c4 and
somebody mentioned the idea of
restricting
all of black's pieces with f3 and d4
then basically all of your pieces are
biting on granite
and in fact white has a huge threat of
just going
f3 e4 and then knight c4
and really going after that pawn on b6
so what this really shows i mean this is
the point i've been making in the speed
run is
sometimes you have to give up quite a
lot in order to gain
uh a serious positional advantage like
when you're playing
positionally that involves weighing the
pros and cons of every move and
at times you have to give up something
like a good square but create a weakness
in return so it's very hard for black to
stop this long-term plan
the computer says that black has to go
here white goes f3
takes takes and um actually bishop takes
d1 is a good idea to
discourage a4 and after knight fd7 you
go c4
and then you try to get this bishop
around to c7 so you attack
that pawn on b6 that pawn is incredibly
incredibly weak that is thank you so
much optic paradox i appreciate it that
is actually a very deep
idea and of course that's not given as
the solution so even
augur yeah so that's a move that you
sometimes play
just uh because you play it or yeah
that's a very
a deep common noobs or yeah noobs or
geniuses
that's a very very deep b5 so just to
recap the idea here
is that you fix you fix the pawn on b6
and even though yes the knight gets this
square that knight doesn't have any
prospects on c5 it's just sitting there
aguard wanted king f1 it's just sitting
there and black is saddled with this
long-term weakness of this pawn
in addition black has to reckon with
this idea of f3e4 and one of the um
the exercises that i showed nemo another
five bucks from paragram thank you
another um uh exercise
that i showed nemo is um
precisely this idea of using pawns to
restrict
to restrict uh the pieces of the
opponent that's a very common technique
it particularly in the end game so
here's that problem
now i think you guys can can appreciate
maybe fully the
the depth of this kind of idea uh and
okay so this position one moment please
one moment please and maybe this was not
worth the setup but this position
occurred in
uh english against steinitz 1883.
and basically uh we have this situation
where
oh yeah i should make the board a tiny
bit smaller so that the
the letters fit maybe even a tiny bit
smaller than that
uh but basically we can see here that uh
that um
it's it seems like an equal position it
seems like maybe black is only slightly
better
at most but it turns out that if you
look at the knight and the bishop what
they really
have access to the bishop has access to
this diagonal the knight to the square
so of course steinitz plays b6
and then he plays c5 and he completely
restricts completely restricts this
knight which no longer has access to d4
and also restricts the bishop which no
longer has access to the
um diagonal so this is a pretty basic
idea but
you can see it kind of replicated in
that position we looked at where white
has to move the knight around
and then play f3 e4 so um
that is pretty pretty impressive idea in
certain positions and i know that you
guys
all kind of thought of this pretty
quickly but nonetheless that's uh
that's a very very instructive idea
thank you shkipe 33 for the five bucks
as well
steinitz won the game steinitz won uh
this game and you know rightfully so he
he was a very very impressive positional
player for his time
okay um but let's pause the training
there we solved a couple of these very
very tough positional exercises
well if the knight jumps back to d2 well
where is it going from there
you can play something like bishop d5
and you can rest
yeah the advantage is it's not sly i
mean it's pretty significant but that's
what you have to do when you play
positionally is
you do have to accumulate these small
advantages so
what you notice here is that the knight
is fully restricted if you go to f3
then perhaps you can consider taking on
f3 and ruining white spawn structure
um or you could stick a rook on d3 much
like in in that positional exercise
uh so you know we can definitely do more
but it's this is i feel like this is
very
uh high brain activities so maybe i'll
finish uh with a couple of blitz games
before i raid
uh coach coach peter and because you
know i think that
positional exercises or high level
training needs to be done in relatively
short bursts
uh rather than like forcing yourself to
do 15 problems at a time that's what i
always tell my students when i give them
difficult problems it's not about
solving
15 problems today it's about solving
three or four problems but really
extracting the key lessons
from those problems as much as you can
alright